inside Venezuela it's a losing battle to
save those who become ill the country's
crumbling health service has all but
fallen here the patients are stacked up
in corners knowing the odds are they
won't leave here any time soon and many
won't make it out at all one of the few
medics still working tells us they're
only taking emergency cases and everyone
has to buy their own medicines bandages
even gloves and Gloria can't afford them
she says she needs a metal pin for her
broken leg but with no supplies she
faces a long wait and they're using
water bottles to keep the weight - as to
try and keep the traction Gloria's in
terrible pain wincing continuously when
do you think she will be able to have
the surgery
about animals in there she'll have to
wait a month maybe two months or three
months well she's done I thought that
she and I said oh nothing more Chinese
torture to be here like that they have
to care for that they have to care for
their own relatives because there aren't
enough nurses many of the medics have
given up because they can't survive on
the minimum wage they're being paid
those still here are doing it for
virtually nothing everything here is so
sad I can not help them because help
there is nobody here and they're so
helpless the hiker inflation in the
country has virtually bankrupted the
hospital they struggled to buy light
bulbs and parts of the building have had
to be boarded up completely closed it
because you had no supplies this is in
an opposition controlled area dependent
on funding from the central government
but without money for medics or supplies
it's unusable
dr. Emily Monty low shows us covered
after cupboard empty of all medicines
[Music]
she says doctors can't survive on their
salaries she's paid around 5 million
Bolivar is a month a pack of eggs costs
4 million
everywhere you've turned here there are
heartbreaking stories Anjali has a brain
tumor
the once active 7 year old has become
almost entirely a mobile in just a few
short months but there's no cancer
treatment available in Venezuela once
one of the richest countries in Latin
America she wants to take her daughter
to Colombia where she can get help there
but she needs the paperwork but how are
you coping
because she's my daughter she says I
have to support her and do everything I
can to help her
we've been here for two months every
second is a titanic struggle for Cesar
his father brought him in with diarrhea
which they couldn't treat and multiple
complications followed what did he used
to like doing the star circuit it was
thought I said playing soccer riding a
bike playing with the tablet he signals
his father calls him a miracle most with
him in ICU died but he needs antibiotics
now which they certainly don't have this
is a nightmare
there are lots of factors source young
social economical legal political and
the politics are having a brutal impact
for Cesar and his father
the nightmares not over even so the
young boy waves goodbye nodding as his
father asks if he's okay Alex Crawford
Sky News in Venezuela